It's got the largest cast, and cash prize, in
TV history, but is "Squid Game: The Challenge"
even legit? Here's why some contestants
say the game was rigged from the start.
Anyone who watched Netflix's hit 2021
South Korean drama "Squid Game" knows
that the fictional dystopian game in question —
wherein 456 people desperate for financial help
fight to the death for a $4.56 million
cash prize — is brutal and unforgiving.
According to a report in Rolling
Stone from February 2023,
the streamer's reality competition
show based on the series — and
offering the same cash prize — was,
if not lethal, also pretty brutal.
Not only were filming conditions during
one specific game reportedly horrible,
but some former contestants made claims
that the entire thing was rigged.
For their part, Netflix and its
co-producing studio partners deny
claims of a fixed game, telling Rolling Stone,
"Any suggestion that the competition is rigged
or claims of serious harm to players are simply
untrue. We’ve taken all the appropriate safety
precautions, including after care for contestants
— and an independent adjudicator is overseeing
each game to ensure it’s fair to everyone."
But some contestants were exceedingly blunt
about what went down when they
spoke to the outlet. One said,
"It was just the cruelest, meanest thing I've
ever been through. We were a human horse race,
and they were treating us like horses out in
the cold, racing, and [the race] was fixed."
So, how was the race fixed, exactly? One
part of the exposé claimed that during
the filming of the "Red Light, Green Light" game,
some contestants successfully crossed the
finish line, only to still get eliminated.
Their ink-filled "squib packs" — which simulate
gunshots and signal a contestant's elimination —
allegedly exploded way after the fact. That group
didn't take it well. One contestant recalled,
"It really wasn't a game show. It was a TV show,
and we were basically extras in a TV show."
We all know that reality shows
manipulate scenarios and make
careful edits to ensure certain outcomes.
Contestants on "The Challenge," though,
have alleged that the on-set behavior from
producers was nothing short of egregious.
Take this example from a contestant who claims
that she was eliminated even though she got across
the "Red Light, Green Light" finish line with
five seconds still on the clock. It was then,
as she was waiting to leave, that
she saw that a contestant and his
mother were still being filmed ... and
not only that, but the show allegedly
added time to the clock off-camera just to
feature the duo. The contestant claimed,
"This kid is sitting at the
finish line, he's crying,
and cameras are on him and he's waiting for
his mom. They added [more time] to the clock
for her to get across because she was one of
the people that they wanted to be in the show."
"My mom, she was like a superstar
athlete. It's like, I just feel
like she's going to—she's going to outlast me
and embarrass me in front of all my family."
Regarding the nine-hour shoot for the "Red
Light, Green Light" game, which was filmed
inside an airplane hangar, contestants
made some extremely serious accusations.
Namely, they said that they were forced to
maintain frozen poses for the bulk of the
nine hours, only moving from time to time ...
a condition made worse by the fact that they
weren't appropriately dressed for the allegedly
freezing cold temperatures inside the hangar.
The icy conditions — as low as 14 Fahrenheit,
according to the Rolling Stone report — led
to some contestants getting sick and collapsing,
and while medics attended to the fallen players,
people in pink "Squid Game" guard suits
would block the process from view so
everybody else could stay frozen
in place. One contestant revealed,
"People were beating themselves up, including
myself, around the fact that you've got a
girl convulsing and we're all stood there
like statues. On what planet is that even
humane? [...] It played on our morals
and it's sick. It's absolutely sick."
Other injuries contestants say they incurred
during filming include a herniated disc,
a torn knee tendon, pneumonia, and ear infections.
One contestant told Rolling Stone that,
despite the game's origins, a brutal survival
experience wasn't what they were expecting:
"It's not like we signed up for 'Naked
and Afraid' or 'Survivor,' where you're
gonna eat ants and it's gonna be
grim — that was not the game."
And another contestant mused,
"The funny thing is, equality and fairness was
the main theme of the original Squid Game."
Was it, though? The competition
depicted in "Squid Game" was a brutal,
predatory exercise created by wealthy
sadists who treated human life with little
to no respect. The contestants were, to put
it lightly, manipulated into participating,
and were targeted due to their
precarious financial positions.
Not only that, but if they moved during "Red
Light, Green Light," or lost a game of tug of war,
they were quite literally killed on the spot. None
of this is to say that the alleged misconduct on
the set of "Squid Game: The Challenge" is
acceptable in the slightest. It is to say,
though, that perhaps a reality
competition series based on such
a terrifying and ugly prospect is sort
of an iffy concept in the first place.
As another contestant put it,
"There's $4.5 million up for grabs [...] These
people were willing to die. [Someone] says,
'I'm going home with this, I don't care what
it takes.' I think the producers wanted that.
They wanted people to not think about their
health, to not care about their safety."